i'm offering you the opportunity to
become a kingsman agent
like a spy of sorts
since 1849 kingsman taylors have clothed
the world's most powerful individuals by
1919 a great number of them had the
desire to preserve peace and protect
life
our founders realized that they could
channel wealth and influence for the
greater good
and so began an independent intelligence
agency operating at the highest level of
discretion
the kingsman agency
welcome to the club very clever
this movie really is an origin story
this is the foundation of the kingsman
franchise
manners maker man
spectacular eh
yes very nice we see you in this film
the formation of the kingsman get to the
lift
the styles very matthew vaughan
matthew is an amazing storyteller and
he's written something quite powerful
at the center of this particular
kingsman film is the first world war
but it still has its recognizable
kingsman element
forget your manners oh
it's called a tailor shop it's got
complicated fight sequences
there's gadgetry of humor and action and
fantastical
villains it's time to pour fuel
on the fire
armed and ready we shall see
welcome why is it that boys are always
so messy
you're going to need a suit come on
[Music]
you